The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Why do people save?
Well, that seems like--
I assume you know the
answer to that.
Well, one answer is the
economics, in the sense of two
standard answers to
that question.
One is consumptions smoothing.
Consumption smoothing
is the idea--
what's consumption smoothing?
AUDIENCE: It means you're living
kind of like-- let's
say one day I purchase all these
different things and I
eat really well on this day,
but tomorrow I starve.
The idea is that I'd spread it
out over a period of time so
that each day I would have the
maximum possible to make it as
easy as possible over
all those days.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So not have too much variation
in consumption.
And what's life cycle?
It's another code word
that economists use.
What's the life cycle
reason to save?
AUDIENCE: Special events in a
person's life, like childbirth
or marriage, [INAUDIBLE] with
your parents, marriage.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so saving for
special events in your life.
What's the most important event
a lot of people in the
US save for?
Retirement.
So I think, among other
things, saving for--
you guys are kind of revealing
your age, I guess.
But retirement is the
single biggest
reason why people save.
And that's one life cycle
event which is very
predictable.
At least, if you get there,
you'll need money.
And then as you said, other
events you can predict, like
your child's wedding, own
wedding, child, but all kinds
of other predictable events.
Any others?
Any other reason to save?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
or an opportunity.
Like, maybe you want to start
a business [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
The last reason, very important
reason is to take
advantage of opportunities.
Starting a business is one.
What else could you do
if you saved up?
AUDIENCE: Buying a home,
buying land.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Buying home, buying land.
Just paying for school fees.
Sometimes, many places you have
to pay a big part of the
school fees at the beginning
of the year, so you want to
have money saved up so that
when this beginning of the
year shows up, you can
pay the school fees.
So there's are all kinds of
very standard reasons why
people save.
So now coming to why
they may not save.
So sometimes, I'm going
to say, it's
efficient not to save.
What are situations where
you shouldn't save?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So one possibility is that
today, your marginal utility
of consumption is very high.
You're sick, and you
need money today.
But let's say on a more
long-term basis, is there a
situation where it makes sense
not to save, even over five
years or something.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, if you know if
you save, and then you're not
going to get very much back from
the savings, there isn't
much point.
For instance, if the money you
put away under floorboards
rots or something like that.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Another possibility is that it's
may be you can't save, or
it's just difficult.
High inflation--
you have to save in money,
and so that makes
it you can't save.
But I'm asking an even
simpler question--
or, maybe not simpler, but
different question, which is,
imagine that you could save--
there's no problem saving--
would there be a situation where
you would actually find
it optimal not to save?
AUDIENCE: If you didn't expect
to be [INAUDIBLE]
by it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So one possibility is that you
have lots of money now, and
the future looks very sharp, you
should not save for sure.
But that's something
important.
We'll come back to it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If Social Security
is very good, state-based,
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if, for example, you
are in the US, social.
security covers a large part
of your earnings if you are
poor, and not a large part of
your earnings if you're rich.
So if you happen to be quite
poor, you know that actually
once you turn 65, Social
Security is going to start
paying you a fair
amount of money.
And let's say Social Security
pays you $30,000 a year.
You're making $20,000
a year now.
There's no reason for
you to save, right?
So Social Security, the
government has guaranteed you
$30,000 a year once
you're retired.
You are 62, you're making
$20,000 a year.
You have no reason to save,
because you know actually, if
you saved, your consumption
today would go down to, let's
say, $15,000.
And then your consumption after
retirement will go up to
$35,000, but that
makes no sense.
You want to actually smooth.
So the general principle--
what's the general
principle there?
Much more generally, where
would you expect
people not to save?
AUDIENCE: When they're expecting
[? some money ?]
might not be worth what
it is now [INAUDIBLE]
where there's not really
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you are saying there's
no way to save.
But let's assume there's
a way to save.
I'm just asking the general
principle from the Social
Security example.
Think about it, what's the
general principle.
When do you want to not save?
AUDIENCE: When the utility of
the money becomes [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Which means what?
AUDIENCE: You're saving less.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: When you say usually
money decreases over
time, what are you saying
about the future?
AUDIENCE: Maybe that you'll
burn more [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You're
getting richer.
Imagine you were someone
who expects to
get richer over time--
a lot richer over time--
that person should not be
saving, because if I think my
wages are going to grow at 10%
a year, then I have no
business trying to save,
because essentially my
consumption tomorrow in any case
will be higher, even if I
didn't save any.
So I have no reason to save.
So if I think the future's a
lot better than today, I
should not save.
That's a general principle about
savings, which is that
you're trying to make
small consumption.
If you're trying smooth
consumption, and you know your
consumption is going to be
non-smooth in any case, then
you want to counteract
that by not saving.
So in general, people
who expect--
so here's a fact.
I'm not going to actually
spend a lot of time
elaborating on it--
today at least--
which is, what's the country in
the world which is growing
the fastest?
Or at least, one at of the
countries in the world.
AUDIENCE: China.
PROFESSOR: China.
Do you know what the personal
savings rate in China is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 40%, or 30%.
30%, I think.
[? Possibly ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
So you think of all of these
people whose wages are growing
at 10% a year, or 6-7% a year,
are saving 30% of their
incomes right now.
So it's a very, very odd--
economists are completely
baffled by why Chinese are
saving so much.
So that's just to remind you
that this sort of analysis we
went through actually has a very
clear implication, which
happens to false, which is the
Chinese should be not saving,
because their wages are
going up very fast.
Our theory clearly said that,
and we don't really know why
they say so.
Well, we have some theories.
I might come back to
that next time.
But I want to just keep this
general principle in mind,
which is that the one solid
reason not to save is you
expect your income
to grow a lot.
Whether that works
or not isn't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] essay,
they can write about
that if they want.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Meaning an essay with
an accompanying reading
about China's and savings.
So if anybody's interested.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so that's
a good topic to write.
Chinese savings is a great topic
to write an essay about.
OK, another reason people often
cite for why people
don't save is they don't
have any money.
How could they save?
Does that argument make sense?
When does it make sense?
So it's a very common
argument.
How could the poor save?
They don't have any money.
Is savings primarily
about having money?
So let me put it differently.
To a first approximation,
savings is about making sure
that there isn't a future where
I've eaten everything
that I have.
So if I have money today, unless
I expect to get richer
tomorrow, then even if I'm poor,
I should save, because
it's not about whether
I have money or not.
If I'm poor today, then I'm
going to be poor tomorrow.
Then it's no different
from I'm rich
today, I'm rich tomorrow.
We have the same incentives to
save, because what you're
trying to achieve is efficient
division of consumption
between today and tomorrow.
So the fact that I'm poor
should not, per se, say
anything about whether I should
save or not, because
savings is about trading off
consumption today with
consumption tomorrow.
And that same trade-off
exists, whether
you're poor or rich.
If I'm poor, I still
have it tomorrow.
And if I have it tomorrow,
then I should still save.
Because if I'm worried that
tomorrow I'm not going to have
any money, that's true
for somebody poor
and somebody rich.
So the fact that I have
little money today--
if I'm going to have even less
money tomorrow, I should save.
So it's not about how much money
you have, but how much
money you expect to have
in the future.
That's the same general
principle that we
went through a minute.
Having said that, is there a
case where being poor might
make you not save?
What's a case where this
argument kind of fails?
AUDIENCE: Well, if your income
is so small that you have to
consume all of it today just
to make it tomorrow.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Excellent example.
So one reason even the poor
may not want to save if
they're really so poor that
tomorrow will not show up if
they don't eat today.
In that case, there's no
argument for saving, because
then you would, in any
case, not get there.
So you're desperately poor and
you're starving, you probably
shouldn't save.
But if you're not that poor,
then the fact that you don't
have income should not
matter that much.
Or even a lot of income should
not matter that much.
So another example how many of
you already suggested, another
argument for why people don't
save is that people just don't
have opportunities to save.
Like many of you suggested,
inflation.
So imagine that the only
way I can save is by
keeping cash at home.
And prices go up, so cash
becomes less valuable.
In other words, there's just no
point in trying to save in
that world, because you're in a
hyperinflation or something,
and any money you put away
is going to be valueless
tomorrow, why bother saving?
So one answer to that is that,
well, why not put it into a
bank account, or into an
investment account?
So you buy something that
that's inflation-proof.
Why don't you buy an
inflation-proof government
bond or something?
So there are assets.
You could buy gold.
So if you still make the
argument that the poor are
particularly handicapped,
because they don't have a
place to save, you have to make
the argument that they
have less access to
bank accounts.
And that's true.
In the world, it's true.
It's completely true that the
poor have very limited access
to bank accounts.
Most countries--
like below 20% of the poor- have
access to bank accounts.
So that's very true.
And if you take investment
accounts or other money market
accounts, or other accounts
which are protected against
inflation, that's
even more true.
Very few people have
access to them.
But why is that?
Why don't the poor have access
to bank accounts?
Why should it be that
they have not
access to bank accounts?
What are arguments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They might live in a
region where it doesn't make
sense to have a bank.
Like, if you're in a small-world
village, there's
really not the infrastructure
or the skill for the bank to
be sustainable there.
Likewise, the size of their
deposits might make it where
even if they are in, say, urban
slum, where there might
be banks generally around them,
banks aren't interested
in catering to them because
there are certain fixed costs,
like we've seen in certain money
lending, that the size
of their deposit wouldn't be
worthwhile for the hassle that
it would involve.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's exactly right.
So basic argument is that
whenever I want to have a
deposit-taking institution--
any institution that
takes your money--
once I take your money, there
is a cost of that, which is
kind of fixed, and doesn't
entirely scale with
the amount of money.
So if I'm putting in $5, and the
cost is $5 to take care of
your money, nobody's going
to be willing to do it.
So you need enough deposits
to make a bank work.
What will be reasons why there's
a fixed cost, the
fixed cost of banking?
Why does banking have
a fixed cost?
Why should it have
a [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Well you need to at
least hire some number of
people to set up the system.
[INAUDIBLE]
someone working at the bank,
someone who will keep track of
all the records. things
like that.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I think one version of that
is that banks are required by
law to keep good records of
any deposits they take.
And so even if the deposit is
$5, they can't just say, well,
we're going to just scribble it
down on a piece of paper.
So basically, every deposit that
comes to a bank has to be
recorded in a proper way.
Given that, even if it's $5,
somebody has to have a
computer there, open a computer,
enter the amount
into the computer, send
it to some place.
So there's a lot of reasons
why they're
fixed costs of banking.
And I think that's the single
biggest reason why most poor
people don't have access
to bank accounts.
Now the alternative is
to save at home.
And there are many reasons why
it's difficult to ave at home.
One has something to
do with inflation.
If you keep money and
the prices go up.
Another problem is crime.
You keep money at home,
somebody comes and
takes it, it's gone.
You kept it a bank, it's a
bank's duty to keep it safe.
So that's another reason
why you can do it.
And then there are what I'm
calling the self-controlled
and spouse-controlled reasons.
So self-control is, if I
have money, I spend it.
If I don't have it, maybe
I don't spend It.
So it's in the bank.
It's not in my hand.
I'm not going to be
able to spend it.
If it's really in my pocket,
I'll just spend it.
I see something I
want, I buy it.
What's spouse control?
What do you think it is?
What's your guess?
AUDIENCE: Your spouse might ask
you for money [INAUDIBLE]
because they want it for
something [INAUDIBLE]
based on [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it may well be that some
people in the family might--
this is more general
than that.
So some people in the family
who have money might be
worried that other people in the
family who don't will come
and lay claims on it.
So if you have nothing, you
can say you have nothing.
But if not, your husband or your
cousin shows up and says,
well, you know, I really
need some money.
I feel like I drink, or I
want to buy something.
How do you say no to people?
So one other issue that
arises is that--
at least, you hear a lot of
reports of-- is people saying
that, look, I don't keep money
at home, because if it does,
then somebody always shows
up and asks for it.
And it could be a spouse, could
be your brother, could
be some friend.
But if there's a lot of people
who come and ask money from
you, then you may actually not
want to keep money at home.
Now the poor have evolved a lot
of different ways to save.
One of them is called a ROSCA.
Do you know what a ROSCA is?
Who knows what a ROSCA is?
AUDIENCE: It's like a type of
merry-go-round [? layover ?]
attributes a set amount And then
a particular day, you get
all the money from the ROSCA.
PROFESSOR: And then what
happens after that?
AUDIENCE: I mean, it continues
usually until a set point
where it stops.
PROFESSOR: But like, let's
say five or four
of us are in a ROSCA.
So we all put in $10.
What happens?
AUDIENCE: So you all put in $10,
and each individual in
the ROSCA gets that lump sum
on alternating days.
So each individual will get
the lump sum at some point
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So one form of ROSCA is one
where there's a fixed order.
We all join the ROSCA.
We have a lottery.
And then the lottery decides
the order of people.
Somebody goes first, somebody
goes second, somebody goes
third, somebody goes
four, somebody goes
fifth, let's say.
They're five people
in the ROSCA.
Now once that's set, then what
happens is that first day,
everybody puts in,
let's say, $10.
And Mr. One gets all of it.
Next week, everybody puts $10,
and Mr. Two gets all of it.
And so, in the end, everybody
gets all $50.
But a lottery determines
who gets it first.
So if you think of a ROSCA,
what's the advantage of a
ROSCA over just saving
at home?
Is there an advantage?
What are the advantages?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You don't need the
discipline to make sure that
you're saving money, because
if you have money at home,
people tend feel tempted
to ask [INAUDIBLE]
use it.
PROFESSOR: So you get
your $50, and then
isn't that a problem?
AUDIENCE: But you have a larger
amount of money that
you can use for a larger
investment, versus like the
$10 you might use that on a
short amount [? of time ?].
PROFESSOR: So you're saying,
if i have a goal associated
with the money, then I'm going
to join a ROSCA where-- let's
say I need $50 one
of these days.
Then I'm going to join
a ROSCA, which has
the price of $50.
That way, when I get it, I buy
it, rather than if I have to
save up to $50, then I'll
have $5 someday.
I'll have $42, but not $50.
And therefore, I still can't buy
the thing I want to buy,
but I now have $42.
Maybe I feel like maybe I could
spend $2 out of that on
some pack off cigarettes
or something, and so.
And you never reach $50.
So the fact that there's a
matching between the amount of
the ROSCA and the
amount to what I
want to buy is important.
That's part of the reason to
solve the self-control problem
is because of this matching.
Because once I have the money,
I can just spend it.
If I need $50, if I have to save
up to it, then there'll
be a lot of times when
I have less than $50.
And I could say, well, maybe
I'll just spend $2 out of it,
and wait another day,
and put in $2 back,
you never get there.
Whereas this gives you $50
all at once, and you
immediately spend it.
So one advantage of it is
delivers the amount you want.
What's another advantage?
Think of the group of us.
Let's say we each need $50.
How long on average would it
take us to get to $50 if we
saved by ourselves, and we
saved, let's say, $10 a week?
AUDIENCE: The advantage of a
ROSCA would be potential for a
immediacy, access to the
large sums of funds.
And even if you're the last
person in the ROSCA, that
amount of time it takes you to
deal with that amount of money
would be the same as if you were
saving it by yourself,
whereas the guy who's first gets
it immediately, and then
it averages out to half the
amount of time [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So if you save $50, it would
take five weeks for each of
you, whereas the expected delay
for somebody in a ROSCA
is two and a half weeks,
because the
Mr. One gets it today.
Mr. Two gets it in a week.
Mr. Five gets it in five weeks,
but he's the last.
So you bring it forward by
two and a half weeks.
So it's a large gain.
You immediately get a
large gain from it.
So that's another
big advantage.
So one is that it solves the
self-control problem.
Another is it just brings it
forward to where you want.
Now you know what a
bidding ROSCA is?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's when people bid
for the right to get the money
this time around.
So if you get, say, an amount of
$50, you might bid up to, I
don't know, [INAUDIBLE], but
realistically up to maybe $25
or so just for the right
to get the money today.
PROFESSOR: Right.
A bidding ROSCA is instead of
having a fixed order, we bid
on who's going to
get it today.
So after we each put in $10
dollars, then the bidding
opens, and whoever wins.
So we basically say that,
look, I paid my $10.
I'll pay $10 extra
to get the $50.
And then next week, somebody
else would do the--
maybe he'll say, I'll pay $4
dollars extra to get the $50.
And then the guy who gets it
last, obviously, is going to.
And what's happening, notice,
is that the pot
is now going up.
So I pay $10 into the pot
to get the extra $10.
That can be distributed
among everybody else.
And so, everybody else is
paying less to get $50.
And if the person who gets
it today is paying
more to get the $50.
So instead of everybody paying
$50 to get $50, some people
are paying $60 and some
people are paying $40.
Now why would that make sense?
What's the advantage of that/
why would we want to have a
bidding ROSCA, rather than
a fixed order ROSCA?
AUDIENCE: Because that means
that it rises for a year,
[INAUDIBLE]
rises earlier than you were
scheduled, so you want to make
the argument earlier.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you may want to be able to
express your preferences.
You might be able to say, look,
I just discovered I have
this opportunity if I buy this
bale of cotton, I can produce
these shirts, and sell them
for a lot of money.
I need the money now, so
I'm going to step in.
I'm going to put in the money
now quickly, and it's worth it
for me to pay some extra.
What's the advantage
of the other?
So basically, what's the
advantage of that too is
others, it's effectively like I
am paying interest to other
people, right?
What it works out to be is if I
am bidding to get it early,
I am paying more.
That's like saying other people
are getting interests
on their savings.
So they they're paying
$10, but I'm actually
giving them $10 back.
So they're getting some interest
on their savings.
This turns it into much
more like a bank.
A bidding ROSCA is much more
like a bank, because it's a
way for us to decide, I want the
money now, I pay the extra
to others to get it.
So it turns it into much
more like a bank.
Now, we talked about the
advantage of ROSCAs.
What are the disadvantages?
What is a ROSCA not good for?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: ROSCAs can be very
short-lived because the cycle
only goes on for as long
as you have members.
So if you're looking to save
over a long period of time,
the ROSCA probably doesn't
meet your need.
And it's also inflexible that
every member has to save the
same amount at the same time.
And so, if you have a variable
income, then it might not be
suitable for you to try to
save that same amount
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So two disadvantages.
One is it's inflexible.
You are to put in $10 every
time, and if your income is
variable, you may not want
to save $10 every time.
And the other is that it's
typically short-term.
So if you want to save for
retirement, it's not a very
good way to get there, because
it's something that takes--
it's going to end fairly so.
And therefore, you're not going
to be able to save for
retirement using it.
Any other disadvantages or
limitations, let's say?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the amount in ROSCAs tend
to be quite limited, and
they're limited precisely by
the fact that it creates an
incentive problem.
Once I've got the money,
I got my $50.
At that point, I have
no incentive
to stay in the ROSCA.
So you need leverage over me.
And if that was $10,000, you
may not have that much
leverage over me.
So $50, the ROSCA will be small,
that I can save small
amounts with ROSCA.
It's going to be hard to save
a large amount, because
somebody's going to be
very tempted by it.
So one other way people save--
I remember, the house I grew
up in India was built--
my grandfather used to write
textbooks for high school.
And whenever he got a contract,
he would build
another room in the house.
So the house was like--
the first rooms were
built in 1939.
The last room was
built in 1959.
20 years, he kept
adding rooms.
And that was because there
were not very many good
savings products available.
And well, for him, it was
something that was going to
always have value.
And so, for him, it was a very
logical way whenever he got
some money, he would
park it into
another room in the house.
So if you look, every
room in the house
has a different floor.
And you can tell that the tiles
that were used to buy
for room one had run out by the
time you got to room two,
because that was five
years later.
So there was a different
set of tiles,
or different flooring.
So every room had a different
floor, different color,
different tile, something.
And that was very normal in
houses constructed in a
particular period, where
especially access to financial
assets was very limited.
So people didn't have much
financial assets.
They usually save in this way.
Now if you go to developing
countries, one thing you
notice is this tons and tons
of unfinished houses.
Like just in the outskirts of
any big city, you see all
these houses which are
half-finished.
Like there's a couple of walls,
or a wall and a roof,
but then on the roof there are
still these pillars sticking
up from the roof, and the
house is not painted.
It doesn't have any doors.
That's a reflection of exactly
the same fact-- people are
actually building these houses
over time, partly because they
don't have good credit markets,
so they can't borrow
to build the house, partly
because they don't have good
savings opportunities.
This a perfect way to solve
their savings problem.
They're getting an asset
in the long run.
And so when my mother had
somebody who used to drive her
car for her, and he would, like,
once in three months,
take leave and go build
a wall in his house.
And he didn't even build
a whole wall.
He would just have
enough money.
He would save up enough money
to build half a wall, and he
would go build half a wall.
And then he's show up two days
later looking all grimy,
because he'd been building
for two days.
Then again, three months
later, he'd
build the next wall.
And now he has a house.
He built his whole house.
He his goal in life was he will
not get married until he
had a house.
So he's now gotten married,
because he had postponed his
whole marriage till he could
build his own house.
So his whole strategy was
he would buy a door--
this was all an investment
towards his marriage.
So once he got all of
that fixed, he went
ahead and got married.
So that's a classic example,
but you see it everywhere.
And it's quite a nice
way to say.
What's a disadvantage?
What's a disadvantage of
saving brick by brick?
What's the obviously
disadvantage?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Stuff can
happen to the
house before it's finished.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Things can
happen to the
house before it's finished.
PROFESSOR: Things could
happen to the
house before it's finished.
That's true.
AUDIENCE: If real value
occurs, then it could
[INAUDIBLE] all of
the investment.
So if you just have
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's not liquid.
It's very illiquid
form of savings.
You can't sell usually
two walls and a door.
So therefore, if you need money
suddenly, it's a very
bad asset to have.
If you knew that there was
a future which was very
predictable, like this guy who
wanted to get married, and he
knew that one day he will
need this, so it's very
predictable--
that's an excellent asset.
But if something which is
unpredictable, then it's a
very bad asset, because
it's very illiquid.
It's like any other
illiquid asset.
Now another similar asset,
which you see a lot in
developing countries,
is jewelry.
You see very poor people wearing
gold jewelry all over
both India and China.
You look at poor people, even
very poor people are wearing
gold, having a small piece
of jade or something.
These things are expensive.
But again, part of the reason
is that they are very good
real assets.
They are inflation-proof.
Gold goes up.
Actually, right now, gold
is at $1,500, which
is impressive actually.
I wish I bought some
gold last year.
But it's inflation-proof.
It's very divisible.
You can buy very, very
small amounts of it.
You just buy a pair
of earrings.
That's not a lot of money.
And it's sort of nice
while you have it.
You get some use value
out of it.
And partly, gold is very
favored, because the quality
of gold is cheap to verify.
This is why gold was always
made into currency.
And as a result, it's
very liquid.
So if you have a gold jewelry,
you can go to the local
jeweler, and he'll give
you a loan in two
minutes against it.
It's very easy to mortgage
basically, because its quality
is very well known.
If you try to mortgage your
house, people have to come and
do an inspection, figure out
if your house is actually
worth anything or not.
Gold is gold.
And so, you'll find in very poor
neighborhoods, in poor
countries, a jeweler, and the
jeweler's actually somebody
who's constantly giving
and taking money.
It's very much a two-way
business.
He's taking gold and giving
money, and giving gold and
taking money.
And it goes in both directions
all the time.
And the reason why gold is
essentially a more attractive
asset-- it has less use
value than a house.
Obviously, a house--
maybe not.
I don't wear a lot
of gold, so.
But
I suspect it has less use value
than a house, but it has
a lot more liquidity.
It's extremely liquid.
You can just take it to
the local jewelry,
you get money back.
So liquidity is extremely
important for the poor,
because there are often
problems, and if somebody gets
sick, you need money.
The alternative to all of this
is financial savings of one
form or another.
Some form of financial
savings.
Financial savings are
like assets in
banks, or paper assets.
Now these are different ways
to access paper assets.
Even if you don't have a bank
account, these are ways to
access paper assets.
Does anybody know what
a money guard is?
Maybe you're going to do your
readings a bit more carefully
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If someone
else [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
A money guard is somebody in
your neighborhood who just
accesses a bag.
AUDIENCE: How does that differ
from a savings collector?
Isn't that basically what
a savings collector--
PROFESSOR: No, a savings
collector--
how does it differ from?
Anybody want to try
to answer that?
AUDIENCE: Is that where they
actually visit your house on a
regular basis, collect
small amounts?
PROFESSOR: Savings collectors
typically
take you to the bank.
So the difference is a savings
guard is someone
who keeps it herself.
AUDIENCE: But I thought in the
reading the woman in the
village, I didn't think she
was taken to the bank.
They said--
PROFESSOR: She was depositing
it somewhere else.
AUDIENCE: And not
at her house?
So really, the only
distinction is
where they keep the--
PROFESSOR: Yes, but I think
it's very different.
The incentives are
very different.
So imagine that you deposit all
your savings with me, and
you have no documentary proof.
I say, well, tough, I have
no idea where it went.
What do you do?
If somebody is putting it in
the bank, then the maximum
they can steal from you
is that today's flow.
So if you put it in the bank,
then I give it to them.
They put it in the bank, they
get this stamp in a book that
says that they put
it in a bank.
I know that essentially all they
can steal is the amount
they collected today, not be the
entire stock up to today.
AUDIENCE: So when they put it
in the bank, aren't they
[INAUDIBLE] in your
bank [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The could either
put it in your name, or
sometimes what people do is
they have to put in--
let's say 10 of us have to each
give you $1, and you have
to put in $10 into the bank.
So it's an easy check.
AUDIENCE: But I mean, assuming
that, couldn't the savings
collector--
I mean, if the bank [INAUDIBLE]
their bank, can
they still steal everything
that they [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's not
in their name.
Typically, they can't
take it out.
The accounts are such that
it's deposited into an
account, and to take it
out, somebody else has
to authorize it.
So these are different designs,
because in some
sense, if there's somebody in
your neighborhood who is very
reliable, you can just
give them the money.
Somebody very reliable, they
can save the money for you.
But if you don't have somebody
very reliable in your
neighborhood, then you often
use a savings collector.
Savings collector is basically
someone who doesn't hold on to
the money, and therefore is
much less able to run away
with the money.
What are self-help groups?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's where a group
of people basically collect
and they stay together
[INAUDIBLE]
the process.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
But a self-help group,
in a sense, is more
flexible in a ROSCA.
It basically takes the money.
Whoever gives them money, they
take it, and then they lend it
to other people within
the group.
Or, sometimes what they
do is they just
deposit it in a bank.
That sort of turns them into
a savings collector.
So I think the more--
AUDIENCE: But isn't a ROSCA a
type of a self-help group?
PROFESSOR: Yes, I guess
you're right.
You're right.
ROSCA is a type of self-help
group, but a lot of self-help
groups are much more flexible
than a ROSCA.
They allow you to the option
of putting the money into--
I put whatever, either $2,
$1, et cetera, into it.
So the trade-off between a ROSCA
and a self-help group is
that as self-help group--
particularly the ones that
work well--
have to have a good
accountant.
A ROSCA is very simple.
We don't need to have
any accounting.
We know there's $10.
We put it in each.
There's $50.
Somebody gets it.
Requires zero accounting,
right?
A ROSCA requires zero
accounting.
Self-help group requires some
accounting, and there's some
evidence that when there's no
one that can do accounting,
they collapse.
Because you basically need to
make sure, I'm making a
flexible deposit.
I'm putting $3 today, you put
in $5, and she borrows $7.
So somebody has to keep track
of all those numbers.
And that's much harder if you're
not really comfortable
with reading and writing.
So in a sense, a ROSCA is a
very specific, very simple
form of a self-help group, and
it's simplicity is a huge
advantage, because it's
something that
makes it quite clear.
Nobody needs to know accounting
to run a ROSCA,
whereas to run a self-help
group, typically you need to
know some accounting.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
self-help group without
the same [INAUDIBLE]
ASCA [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
An ASCA is a broader category.
Yeah.
Self-help group is an example of
something where there is--
so the trade-off between--
so I already answered
the question.
A savings collector typically
charges money for it.
It's somebody who comes
into your place,
collects the money.
She keeps accounts for it.
She's a professional.
She charges money for it.
People to pay up to 5% per
month, negative interest to
get these things.
So huge.
So you might get might
actually pay
someone quite a lot.
Typically, a self-help group is
one where you don't have to
pay anybody.
It's like a ROSCA, where the
loss is relatively limited.
The constraint is accounting.
So saving collector
is someone who can
typically keep good accounts.
She, or even a money
guard, is someone
who keeps good accounts.
You go and give her the money,
she can show a book where she
keeps exact records of
how much you put it.
It's not easy to find someone in
your neighborhood if you're
poor who has good accounting
skills.
Whereas if you think a ROSCA,
for example, is beautiful in
that it doesn't require
a lot of accounting.
So the trade-off between these
come on how much accounting
they require.
So self-help groups are
intensive in accounting.
They require that somebody keeps
track of who's putting
in money, who's taking
out money.
So if that's not being done
by a professional, then it
depends very much on the
quality of the group.
If there's no one in the group
that can do the account well,
the group will collapse.
If you compare that with like,
say, a savings collectors--
saving collectors typically
are someone who is good at
accounting, and therefore can be
relied on to do that job on
their own--
gets paid for it.
So that sort of the trade-off
between these things, is that
if you have someone around who
is a good accountant who is
part of your group, you can
have a self-help group.
If you're willing to pay
someone a lot to do the
accounting for you, you can
have a savings collector.
And if you have neither,
you can have a ROSCA.
So ROSCA is the simplest
product.
It's the least flexible
But it's the one that doesn't
require any skilled person to
do the job for you.
So that's the big trade off
between these things is that
some of them rely on having
skilled people around to do
the job, other don't.
Microcredit is another possible
savings instrument.
How could that be?
How could microcredit be
a savings instrument?
AUDIENCE: It's like
[INAUDIBLE]
savings [INAUDIBLE]
your fixed savings
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So in a sense, it's a funny
way to save, but a lot of
people to save that way.
So you want a television.
You can either save--
let's say a color
television costs $200.
You can save $2 a week
for 100 weeks.
That's very difficult.
$2 a week, you forget, you
spend some of the money.
You're keeping a lot
of money at home.
The alternative is somebody
gives you $200.
You buy the television, and then
you pay them $2 a week,
but then they charge
you some interest.
You pay $2.50 a week.
But because you're paying $2.50
a week, they're willing
to give you the money early.
And then it is their job
to make sure you pay.
They come and pester you
if you don't pay.
So you transfer the burden of
repayment, and in instead you
having to do the saving,
somebody else forces you to do
the saving.
It's expensive.
You're paying 24% a year
to get save, basically.
It's like giving up 24% of your
money, but it has this
advantage that you don't
have to wait.
OK, so some little math.
So all of this we've
been discussing.
We've been sort of going back
and forth, and saying, well,
it's difficult for
the poor to save.
Maybe they don't want to save.
Maybe there's some good reason
why they don't save.
So we haven't shown any smoking
gun that there really
is an efficiency in savings.
So I wanted to give you an
example of how you would make
the reason that is actually
people actually under-save.
So how would you make the case
that people under-save?
So to me this case, we'll have
to do a little bit of algebra.
So let's think about
it carefully, OK?
The first line in that
slide is what's
called the Euler equation.
The Euler equation is a
condition for savings
optimality over time.
What it says is the marginal
utility of consumption today--
how much consumption is
worth to you today--
should be equal to--
so something times
[? marginal ?]
consumption tomorrow.
What's the question
being asked?
It's asking the question,
imagine I saved one more
dollar today.
What would it be
worth tomorrow?
Well, one thing that's going
to work is [INAUDIBLE].
So it's going to be
worth 1 plus r.
If the interest is r, I'm going
to get 1 plus r for it.
Yeah?
But then, utility tomorrow isn't
worth as much as it's
work today.
It's like tomorrow
is in the future.
I want it now.
So that's delta.
Delta is a number less than 1.
So it says that utility tomorrow
is worth only a
fraction delta of
utility today.
And then the last is
[? marginal ?]
consumption tomorrow.
So basically, imagine that the
right-hand side of that is
less than the left-hand
side, OK?
Then, what should I do?
Well, I should [INAUDIBLE]
says the [? module ?]
utility today is higher
than what it
will be worth tomorrow.
Or actually, let's do it the
other way If [? module ?]
utility today is less than delta
times 1 plus r times U
prime [? c ?] plus 1, that means
that $1 today saved will
give me more utility than I
would get it today, right?
Today I will get $1 will give
me U prime [? c ?].
If I saved it, I would
get 1 plus r.
That's going to be worth
delta U prime [? c ?]
times 1 plus r.
So basically, I'm getting more
utility by putting money into
the future.
So that's the standard condition
for consumption
optimality.
The next line says, imagine the
utility function that's a
standard form of the utility
function is that it has that
form, consumption
to the power of
something divided by something.
It's a fairly standard form
of utility function.
Actually, you should notice
that even when sigma is
greater than one, that works.
Why?
Because c to the [? r1 ?] minus
sigma is then decreasing
in c, but is divided by
a negative number.
So it's again increasing by c.
So it works even for that.
So if I did that, then I
substituted U of c into both
sides I would get that the
question in the third line.
The third lines comes from the
second line, U of c equals c
to the power 1 minus sigma
divided by 1 minus sigma, U
prime is then what?
What's U prime?
Take the derivative.
What do you get?
It's MIT.
You know the answer.
Come on.
All too superior to answer?
You all feel like, how
could you ask me
such an inane question?
Tell me what it is.
AUDIENCE: c to the
negative sigma.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, c to the
negative sigma is U prime.
I put that into the
first equation, I
get c to the power.
And then you can see that I'm
gonna get the third line out
of that if I substitute U prime
into that equation.
And then I invert that to
get the fourth line.
Now reasonable values
of delta, standard
values are, like, 0.9.
People use that number
0.9, 0.95.
I'm taking a low number.
You'll see that a low number
is going to make it less.
If I do the higher number,
then my case
will be even stronger.
Sigma, people think it's a
number like two, three, four.
That's the kind of number
of people usually find.
Sigma is a measure of risk
aversion, and when they
measure that, they find
something like that.
So take those numbers.
Trust me, they are
standard numbers.
And then the last thing
is, what is r?
And I want to say that we looked
at data last time where
it said that people were
borrowing at 80% a year.
If you're borrowing at 80%
a year, you're an asset.
That's exactly like having an
asset which pays 80% a year.
Because if I borrowed $1 less,
I would pay $1.80 less on it.
So anybody who had an asset
which has an interest rate of
80% is sitting on an
asset with an 80%
interest rate on it.
It's exactly the same thing.
I just borrow $1 less.
So anybody who has a loan which
is paying 80% is exactly
like having an asset
which is 80% on it.
So now, I plug that in.
So think of somebody who has a
loan, who is borrowing at 80%.
67% of the people-- yeah, we saw
that actually last time,
were borrowing, had loans,
and the average
interest rate was 80%.
So this is not an unreasonable,
these numbers.
So let's take those numbers,
plug them in, and you get
consumption growth will
be 17% per year.
That's a huge growth rate.
That I would say poverty would
vanish in five years, because
17% per year is a very,
very fast growth rate.
What's the logic here?
Say, these guys have an
investment opportunity which
pays 80% a year.
They're not using it.
So there must be, only reason
you don't use an investment
opportunity that's paying that
much is that you're going to
be much richer in the future,
so you don't want to invest.
Otherwise, you should use
this opportunity.
So people who are forward
looking, and they have an
investment opportunity which
paid them 80% a year, they
should be pumping all their
money into the future.
80% a year is a great investment
opportunity.
Only people who will do it are
people who are getting rich
very fast, because if you're
getting rich very fast, then
you don't want consumption
in the future.
So that says that if we take
assume people are rational,
then the fact that people are
persistently borrowing-- and
I'll show you this
in a minute.
I'm not making this
example up.
So I'll show you the problem
in a minute.
The fact that people are
persistently borrowing at 80%
a year means that they must
be getting rich very fast.
But in other words, since
they're not getting rich very
fast, the poor seem
to remain poor.
Something is wrong with this
calculation, so we're going to
try to figure out what's
wrong with it.
But if I take the model
seriously, and say, this is
how people save, it is clear
that this implication is that
the poverty should be the
vanishing phenomenon, because
basically these guys have such
a wonderful investment
opportunity.
You an just save at 80% a year
and get a lot richer.
So that's--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the logic to
why sigma is equal to 3?
PROFESSOR: Sigma
is equal to 3?
So sigma is the coefficient
of risk aversion.
If you look at the utility
function, and you look at--
given that utility function,
how would
people react to risk?
That will be measured
by sigma.
So you can actually
look at how people
actually react to risks.
I offer you $10 for sure, or
$4 with probability 1/3 and
$15 with probability 2/3, and
I see whether you want then
bet are not.
And from that, people back
out of risk aversion.
And to do that, they get
a number like 3.
So this is sort of a hint
at what's going on.
And I want to show you kind of
something more worrying.
So here's an experiment which is
kind of a different way of
getting at the same point.
I showed it to you kind
of theoretically.
Now I want to show it to
you as an experiment.
Here's an experiment.
It's an experiment with fruit
vendors and vegetable vendors
in India and the Philippines.
Two separate experiments
doing identical things.
So fruit vending is a very,
very simple production
function, OK?
Very, very simple, meaning you
buy fruits in the morning, you
sell all day, you get money in
the evening, you go home.
Next morning, you come back,
and you buy fruit again.
You sell it.
It's very predictable, very
continuous, daily production.
Not very high risk, actually.
It's mostly you know what you
can sell, you can see the
price, et cetera.
So here's a table which kind
of summarizes a bit about
these people.
So most of these people make one
trip a day to the market.
This one's for the Indian
experiment.
They buy fruits worth about
1,000 rupees in the morning.
They sell it, and they get
profits of over 100 rupees.
That's the 10% profits
during the day.
Not bad, actually.
How do they run the business?
70% take a loan every day.
Every month--
26 days-- somebody
takes a loan.
So this is to buy fruit.
The interest rate on the
loan per day is 5%.
Basically, the way it works is
you go to the fruit seller,
and he says, you want to
buy cash or credit?
Cash price is this, credit
price is that.
Which one's higher?
AUDIENCE: Credit.
PROFESSOR: Credit price
is higher, right?
Basically, you get the same
fruit, so you pay more if you
buy it in credit.
But the advantage of credit is
you don't have to pay for it
in the morning, you paid
it in the night.
You go back in the evening,
and you pay for it.
5% per day.
So most of these people
have been in--
no, I'm missing one table.
Most of these people have been
in business for nine years.
They do this day after day.
Nine years they've
been in business.
Every day, they borrow at 5%,
meaning that they come in the
morning, they take, let's say,
1,000 rupees worth of fruits,
but they actually get 950 rupees
worth of fruits, and
then they go sell it.
They say this is 1,000 rupees,
but in fact get 950 rupees at
first first, and then
go sell it.
Remember that daily income
is about 100 rupees.
They pay 50 rupees out
of 1,000 as interest.
So if they didn't pay interest,
they're earnings
every day would be 50% higher.
It would go from 100
to 150, roughly.
So that's a huge
interest cost.
Now here's a way to think about
5% a day, what it means.
Suppose I took the following
strategy.
Drink one less couple
of tea every day.
A cup of tea costs,
in this same
currency, 2 and 1/2 rupees.
So let me take one less cup
every day, and I reinvest that
in the business.
So what I do is I drink one less
cup of tea, so I borrow.
2 and 1/2 rupees less today.
That means I don't pay interest
on the 2 and 1/2
rupees, so I get a little
bit extra money.
I reinvest that.
I do that for 30 days.
Every day, I drink one less
cup of tea for 30 days.
At 5% a day--
you should do this
calculation.
It's stunning.
Compound interest really
is impressive.
So once you do this for 30 days,
you would have doubled
your capital.
So these women could double
their capital by simply having
one less cup of tea every
day for 30 days.
They've been in this business
for nine years.
Their earnings would be 50%
more if they did this.
They could pay down their entire
1,000 rupees debt by
doing that for 30
days, basically.
So your 1,000 rupees are
essentially just the price of
30 days worth of tea.
So that's sort of stunning,
if you think about it.
So this goes back to the same
point I was trying to make,
which is that there's some
reason to get worried that
these people are somehow--
they're not managing.
What they're trying to do in
this experiment is they offer
two treatments.
They basically think that two
possible ways in which we
could-- maybe one possibility is
that these people are now--
they need 1,000 rupees to
survive, 100 rupees to eat
every day, so they can't save.
And so they're stuck.
So it's not clear why
they couldn't have
one cup of tea less.
So they say, well, maybe if
we just pay their debt.
So let's say they owe
1,000 rupees, we'll
give them 1,000 rupees.
Imagine that there's some reason
they can't get out it.
Do they stay out of debt if
I pay them 1,000 rupees?
Second possibility is that I
teach them what compound
interest is.
I explain to them that if you
just did this, you could save
yourself a lot of money.
So there are two treatments.
They're experimental, so some of
them get one, some of them
get the other, some
of them get both.
So do you see what the
experiment is?
I either go to someone and say,
you owe the food seller
1,000 rupees.
Here's 1,000 rupees.
You're done.
Now from now on, you
start from scratch.
Or I go to them, and I
say, come to a class.
I'll explain to you
compound interest.
Or, I offer them both.
So what happens?
So that's the question.
So some of these people, for
some reason, they had
got into this debt.
Let's say they were liberated
from the debt.
Some people were educated on
the arithmetic component of
compound interest.
So training was half a day
training, where they were
explained how much they spent
on interest, all these
illustrations.
If you save just one cup
of tea a day, it will
be enough, et cetera.
So all of that.
Skip.
So here's the result.
This one's from the--
[INAUDIBLE]
let's see which country
this is.
Philippines.
From the Philippines.
Here's the basic result.
[? Force ?] times payoff
says if you--
ignore everything else
that says, but just
look at what it says.
Do you have a debt?
The question is, do you have
a debt from a money
lender after two weeks?
That number says you are 33%
less and less likely to have a
debt from a money lender
after two weeks.
So two weeks after I pay your
entire 1,000 rupees down,
you're back to having
a loan for 5% a day.
So 33% don't have a loan,
so 67% have a
loan after two weeks.
After six weeks, 60%
have a loan.
After 10 weeks, 80%
So basically, after 10 weeks,
that 1,000 that they had been
given just vanishes.
They don't seem to be able
to stay out of debt.
The same results
are true for--
this is the India study.
So debt payoff after--
first, follow up.
After three months, so this
negative 10% don't have a
loan, so 90% after three months
have got back a loan.
So even though these the loan
was paid down, that went away
within three months.
And the training, just
2% had nothing.
There was no effect
of training.
OK, you can see, people
were trained.
If you look at the training
row, that row says nothing
significant in that row.
That's just saying that
force times training
is the effect of--
if you had had a training,
what's the
probability you have loan?
It's positive, meaning you're
more likely to have a loan,
but it's suddenly not
significance.
So it's basically no effect
on whether you
have a loan or not.
So the fact they would explain
compound interest seems to
have no effect on whether
you get a loan or not.
It's kind of stunning, actually,
these results.
How are people slipping?
Why are they getting
back into?
So one thing that you
find is that when
they get any shocks--
like somebody gets sick--
if your debt was paid off so
that you were given the money,
you are much more likely to deal
with the shock with your
own money rather than
by borrowing.
So what these people are doing
is they seem to be using the
money to deal with shocks.
So basically, there's so much
uncertainty in these people's
lives that there's always
something that comes up.
And when that comes up,
you use the money to
deal with the problem.
And then you're back borrowing,
basically.
We'll start to think about what
these results mean on
Tuesday, OK?
So think about them.
Do the reading.
We'll talk more about
it on Tuesday.